Bonjour, à tous !
On s‘approche du nombre fatidique
des 10 millions…
[JINGLE SNCF]
Oui, laisse-moi parler !
Vous êtes bientôt 10 millions d’abonnés,
c’est absolument incroyable,
Alors pour fêter ça,
j’ai décidé d’aller à votre rencontre !
Et comme Internet n’a pas de frontières,
Je vais aller dépasser
la frontière française !
Vous en pensez quoi,
c’est une bonne idée ou pas ?
Fan: Merci beaucoup.
Cyprien: Voilà, salut mec !
Alors c’est parti !
[Musique Dynamique]
Le temps de transport n’est pas perdu,
On en profite pour faire du montage.
La vidéo que vous avez
peut-être déjà vue,
Sinon regardez-la, "Le Dessin",
Ca sort tout à l’heure,
mais c’est déjà sorti quand ça sortira,
Bref, c’est très complexe.
[Musique Dynamique
Il fait un temps magnifique,
et ça c’est appréciable.
- Salut !
Fan: On peut faire une photo ?
Cyprien: Avec plaisir.
Cyprien: Vous êtes tellement beau en plus.
Fan Ahah, merci.
Cyprien: Et voilà.
Fan: Super !
Il fait partie
de mes 10 millions d’abonnés !
Enfin bientôt 10 millions !
Pardon !
Ca sent la frite !
Je sens,
on n'est plus très très loin ! Oui !
"Fritland"
Cyprien: Vous mangez des frites, c’est ça ?
Groupe de fan: Oui.
Cyprien: Elles sont bonnes ici, il paraît ?
Groupe de fan: Trop bonnes.
La légende raconte que c’est très bon.
[Musique Epique]
J’ai la pression,
parce que je me sens un peu épié.
[Musique Epique]
C’est le plus beau jour de ma vie.
Cyprien: Tu veux terminer ?
Fan: Non non, c'est bon.
- Mets-toi bien cousin, vas-y !
(rires)
- Un français, il dit «Viens».
Nous on dit «viens une fois».
C’est pour alléger un ordre.
Cyprien: D’accord, un ordre mais gentil.
Homme: Voilà, gentil.
Cyprien: «Bouge de là une fois».
Homme: Voilà c’est ça, «dégage une fois».
On va aller rejoindre les abonnés
pour le meetup à Bruxelles.
C’est par là, peut-être.
Et c’est parti pour le meetup à Bruxelles !
Tous les fans: Ouais !!
Y en a qui ont des chaînes YouTube ici,
à tout hasard ?
Personne ?
Je suis le seul Youtuber ?
Oh ! Merci beaucoup !
Tu sais que je suis fan de mangas,
c’est pour ça ?
Vu que t’es Youtuber, je me suis dit :
c’est l’idéal pour toi.(DeadTube)
Je découvre un manga
où les YouTubers décèdent.
Ca fait super plaisir !
[VOIX OFF]J’ai fais ce voyage
pour célébrer les 10 millions d’abonnés.
Il me fallait un prétexte
pour pouvoir rencontrer les gens,
un petit-peu partout dans le monde.
Je pense que c’est pas trop une mauvaise idée,
parce que sinon,
j’avais pas de plan B… (rire)
Oui ?
- Ca fait quoi quand tu regardes
tes anciennes vidéos ?
- J’avoue que je les regarde pas,
parce que ca me procure
un peu de malaise, mais…
Quand j’ai posté ma première vidéo,
je l’ai postée pour voir
si ça marchait, en fait.
Comme quand on branche
un grille-pain, quoi.
"Ca marche ?
Ah, ça marche."
Bah voilà j’ai fait pareil.
Je me suis dit :
mais là, on va s’amuser là !
On va pouvoir faire tout
et n’importe quoi !
Mais je pensais pas que ça allait devenir,
finalement, mon quotidien.
Vous êtes jumeaux ?
- Oui.
- Bah du coup vous vous envoyez la photo,
ça suffira !
On sent que ça leur a fait plaisir
que je passe ici à Bruxelles.
Ils s’attendaient pas, ils disent :
«Nous, on n’y croyait pas trop.»
Si ! C’est important pour moi
de vous rencontrer.
10 millions c’est un chiffre dingue,
mais ça reste un chiffre.
- C’est pas 10 millions ton objectif ?
Fan: C’est bientôt, là…
Cyprien: Oh ! On s’approche !
Ca serait marrant que ça descende :
«Putain les mecs, on est dans la merde.»
Est-ce que je pourrais avoir
une photo avec toi ?
- Bien sûr !
(rires)
- Oh ! Oh c’est pas vrai !
Natoo: Je suis ta plus grande abonnée belge !
Cyprien: C’est faux !
Ta plus grande fan !
Et je t’ai acheté 10 kilos de frites!
Cyprien: C’est faux, c’est des cadeaux pour toi…
Natoo: Oui !
Sur Snapchat,
j’ai dit que j’étais à "BruXelles",
et sur Twitter je me suis fait insulter,
parce qu’il faut dire «BruSSelles».
Ca, c’est un bus de BruXelles,
c’est typique…
- AH, OH !
"BruSSelles".
- Oui pardon.
J’y arrive pas...
Cyprien: Natoo ?
Natoo: Oui.
Cyprien: T’es prête à goûter une bière belge ?
Natoo: J’adore le malt.
- Eh  bah c’est parti !
Et voilà !
On nous a conseillé la Triple Karmeliet.
Homme: On vous a bien conseillé.
Natoo: C’est une double fermentation.
Si c’est Triple Karmeliet,
c’est triple fermentation !
Oh, bah c’est triple fermentation.
Qu’est-ce que tu fais à Bruxelles ?
Figure-toi qu’on tourne un film !
C’est pour ca qu’elle nous a rejoints !
Ah non ! Je vous ai rejoints
pour boire de la bière !
Ah #LeManoirLeFilm !
Natoo: Et à ta tournée !
Cyprien: Et à ma tournée !
Ben moi, 5h du matin
c’est la meilleure… horaire…
pour être au milieu de sa nuit, n’est-ce pas ?
Il y a tellement de brouillard à Bruxelles
qu’on voit même pas l’avion.
Ah c’est bon,
on le voit enfin l’avion !
(musique typique)
Quand j’ai commencé à chercher
les destinations francophones à visiter,
là où je pouvais aller voir
mes abonnés,
C’est allé de plus en plus loin !
(rire)
Cinq destinations, des endroits
où j’ai jamais mis les pieds,
là je me suis dit :
on part sur quelque chose de lourd !
On est dans le labyrinthe.
Je tombe sur des rues qui tombent sur des rues
qui tombent sur des impasses.
De manière aléatoire,
on devrait réussir à sortir.
Salam !
- Salam !
- Voilà, petit verre d’eau.
Ah bah ouais, la totale.
Je suis swaggé maintenant !
Oh oui, du soleil !
Je suis trempé !
Jean-Michel Trempé, c’est moi.
Eh ben j’ai l’impression que c’est parti
pour rencontrer mes abonnés marocains !
(musique folklorique)
On est sur du typique !
(cris de foule)
Meilleur accueil de la planète,
je pense, hein!
- Tu comptes faire une vidéo
pour les 10 millions d’abonnés ?
- Oui ! Et en fait ce sera la vidéo
de toutes les rencontres que je fais là,
ces quelques jours…
Vous êtes ma vidéo des 10 millions.
(applaudissements)
Je voulais pas faire non plus
un trop gros meetup
parce que sinon je peux pas
discuter avec vous, en fait.
Je me suis dit : je vais plutôt
prendre un peu le temps,
avec un peu moins de gens,
mais des gens qui sont à fond parce que…
Quand on discute avec vous,
ca fait chaud au coeur !
- Un petit cadeau.
- Un petit cadeau ?
C’est le plus beau choix de photo.
Est-ce normal ?
- Elle a appris le français
en re-écoutant tes vidéos !
- C’est vrai ?
- Oui, parce qu'il y a des sous-titres.
- Ah bah elle doit avoir un français
un peu…
parce que mon francais à moi,
c’est pas le meilleur hein !
Si c’est un roumain
qui lui apprend le français, on est mal.
- J’ai été en Roumanie en août.
- Ca t’a plu?
- Oui.
- C’est super hein ?
Si dans mes prochaines vidéos,
je suis obèse,
c’est à cause de vous !
On veut pas que tu dises «au revoir»…
On peut pas y croire !
C’est vrai qu’il ya des questions
qui reviennent souvent,
et on se rend compte
que peu importe le pays où ils sont,
ils ont les mêmes intérêts,
les mêmes questionnements…
Du coup, il y a un truc qui rapproche,
en fait, toutes ces personnes !
On pense pas créer du lien en fait...
On pense juste divertir.
C’est assez dingue quoi…
Maintenant, c’est le moment de partir.
On est restés à peine
plus de 24 heures à Casablanca.
Mais ça veut dire aussi :
une nouvelle destination !
(musique typique)
Je suis accueilli par le Grand JD !
- Salut !
- Julien Donzé,
YouTuber de profession !
- Exactement ! YouTuber suisse !
Bienvenue en Suisse !
- Tu vas me montrer un peu ta ville ?
- Exactement.
- On peut prendre une photo ?
- Bien sûr !
On fait une photo tous ensemble ?
Et voilà !
(brouhaha)
(cor des Alpes)
(cor des Alpes faux)
J’ai l’impression d’appeler quelqu’un en fait.
- Oui, ça servait à communiquer
dans les montagnes de vallée à vallée.
- C’est un système de communication.
- Voilà.
- Est-ce que c’est l’ancêtre de l’iPhone ?
- Non, alors pas du tout.
- Tchin !
- Alors tchin !
- Merci pour l’accueil !
- Eh bien bienvenue en Suisse.
- Julien Donzé, ça fait 10 ans
qu’il fait des vidéos sur Internet.
- Mais toi aussi,
ça fait bientôt 10 ans.
- En février, ça fera 10 ans.
- Et tu te rends compte
que t’as 10 millions d’abonnés ?
- Non, pas du tout.
- A chaque fois que tu sors une vidéo,
tu penses pas à ça ?
- J’évite de me dire
qu’ils sont 10 millions.
Je me dis : "Ils sont 100
et ils sont chauds".
Ce qui est déjà bien, tu vois.
Tu veux savoir
combien j’ai d’abonnés actuellement ?
- Moi je te suis, je les suis…
- Julien Donzé qui surveille
mes statistiques…
Vas-y, fous-moi la pression un peu.
- Donc 9 millions 995 mille… 493 !
- Peut-être qu’on va passer ensemble
les 10 millions ?
- Tu crois que je passe
les 10 millions en Suisse ?
Je sais pas !
Ca va vachement vite !
- Le meetup en Suisse à Genève,
et y a du monde je crois !
(cris)
«…Ainsi périrent
les ennemis de la République !»
C’est vrai que j’ai passé un petit peu
de temps dans la ville,
je sais pas pourquoi les gens
courent tout le temps, c'est incroyable !
On me dit de courir, je cours,
mais je sais pas pourquoi !
La course de ?
- L’Escalade !
- Ici y a des français qui sont venus
nous envahir.
Et nous on les a repoussés,
en chemise de nuit et tout,
avec des casseroles…
- Quand tu dis «nous», c’est pas toi ?
- C’est mon grand-père !
(chants)
- Ah ! La belle Escalade,
Savoyard, gare, gare !
(cris et applaudissements)
J’ai l’impression
que vous allez me sacrifier ensuite…
- Là, t’es presque à 10 millions.
- On est à combien ?
- On est…
Là c’est dans quelques…
- Oh putain...
(cris et applaudissements)
On les a pas encore !
Rah ça fout la pression,
il fallait pas me le dire ça…
(musique de suspense)
- Il manque 100 personnes.
- Mais non ?
- Il manque 100 personnes en direct !
- C’est un truc de fou.
- 50 personnes, ça va,
t’as le temps.
- 50 personnes... Du coup, bah...
On a le temps en fait.
Peut-être que tout le monde
va se désabonner à la fin,
et je vais me retrouver avec 3 abonnés.
- 10 personnes,
5 personnes...
C’est bon !
Les 10 millions ! Il l’a !!
Le million il l’a !
Oh putain comme ça va trop vite !
C’est un truc de malade !
- J’étais pas prêt.
(rire)
J’étais vraiment pas prêt…
Alors, qu’est-ce que…
(musique douce)
Putain...
- C'est magnifique !
- Ca fout la pression.
- C'est vrai ?
- Roh putain...
Je pensais qu’on allait arriver
aux 10 millions
un peu plus tard, dans vraiment
une semaine, 10 jours, et en fait…
Euh...
En fait non, on y est déjà.
Et je suis super content de…
Voilà, je sais pas quoi dire !
(rire)
Moi quand j’ai mis ma première vidéo,
je pensais pas qu’autant de gens
allaient me faire confiance,
ou en tout cas,
soient curieux sur ce que je fais…
Voilà, merci beaucoup,
merci beaucoup de me faire confiance,
d’être très nombreux.
Ca fait très plaisir,
car ça veut dire que
c’est pas dans le vide, ce que je fais.
Y a un truc qu’est sûr, c’est que j’ai hâte
de fêter ça avec plein de gens,
et d’aller les rencontrer demain
dans une autre destination.
Et...
Faire plein d’autres projets aussi.
- Parce que c’est que le début du trip !
Oh la chaleur !
J'ai passé une nuit
très courte dans l'avion.
Mais...
C'est pas grave car on arrive,
il fait 29 degrés,
du coup on pardonne tout.
Oh.. Je vais me foutre à poil là.
(musique dynamique)
- Cyprien !
- Ca va ?
- J’adore tes vidéos.
- C’est très bien ce que vous faites.
- On est même dingues, hein,
raides dingues !
- Oh mais c’est juste énorme !
- Mais j’y crois pas !
Je voulais que ce soit un grand moment
quand je dépasse
les 10 millions d’abonnés,
et rester à Paris, voilà,
devant mon bureau quoi,
c’était pas forcément un bon moment.
Je me suis dit : je vais bouger.
Si je bouge,
faut que je rencontre des gens.
je vais rencontrer des gens
que j’ai jamais rencontrés,
voir des cultures que j’ai jamais vues,
mettre les pieds
là où j’ai jamais mis les pieds.
Je me suis dit : allons loin,
allons au chaud, au froid,
là où il y a des abonnés.
Ca va me mener
un petit peu partout.
- Bonjour !
- Vous avez de la crème solaire ?
- Oui.
- On a trouvé la crème solaire !
- Fais-toi plaisir !
- Eh vous êtes sympas, les mecs.
- On est en stage, ici à la Réunion.
- Stage dans quoi ?
- En informatique.
- En informatique ?
- Ouais.
- C’est ici que ca se passe ?
J’ai l’impression que vous êtes
un peu des charlatans quand même.
(rires)
Merci beaucoup les mecs !
- Si t’as besoin de crème solaire,
tu nous appelles.
- Venir à La Réunion pour faire
un stage en informatique,
moi je dis :
les belges, ils sont forts !
C’est quoi cette température ?
J’étais pas prêt moi ! Vraiment pas prêt.
(brouhaha et rires)
«Le jeune homme
aux 10 millions d’abonnés. »
Pour plein de gens, ça va être la course
à avoir le plus d’abonnés,
mais je pense que c’est pas forcément
la bonne démarche.
Si vous faites ça par intérêt,
pour dire : «Tiens c’est à la mode,
tiens je vais faire des vues, faire de la thune,
tiens je veux être célèbre»…
Ca va se voir.
Mais si vous avez un truc au fond de vous,
vous avez envie de créer,
envie de raconter quelque chose ;
foncez ! Gardez le plaisir !
Partagez ça aussi, faites-le avec des amis,
et franchement ça va cartonner.
(musique joyeuse)
(vagues)
Je sais plus exactement où on est…
On est à la Réunion, c’est sûr,
mais faut que je… C’est dur à réaliser.
Y a toutes les images
qui commencent à se mélanger.
Le vol, toutes les destinations,
tous les pays différents…
T’es où, là ?...
Bouger autant comme ça, changer autant
de destinations en si peu de temps,
j’ai jamais fait ça de ma life !
(musique calme)
Je me rends compte que j’ai déjà
parcouru beaucoup dans mon voyage,
et que j’ai parcouru aussi beaucoup
depuis 10 ans sur Internet.
Je me dis : ne nous arrêtons pas !
Il reste une destination, eh bien…
Allons-y, on fonce !
11 heures de vol.
(musique dynamique)
C’est parti pour 7 heures de vol.
Ce qui va faire du coup
18 heures de vol, au total.
On va faire un bonhomme de neige.
Il faudrait que je trouve de la neige !
Bah j’ai l’impression que j’en ai trouvé !
Comme vous le remarquez,
ça ne marche pas.
Bon après une heure de travail,
j’ai terminé mon bonhomme de neige.
Alors ? Ca vous plaît ? Voilà !
C’est tout ce que j’ai réussi à faire
en 45 minutes.
(rires)
Ah ouais ??
Ma boule !!
Mais... Putain !
Non mais arrête !
Cet homme est fou !!
Mais qu'est-ce qui vous prend ?!
Juste avant de partir, je pensais surtout
aux abonnés que j’allais rencontrer.
Qu’est-ce qu’ils vont penser de ça,
est-ce qu’ils seront contents de me voir,
est-ce qu’ils ne préfèrent pas Squeezie..?
(rires)
J’avais un peu d’appréhension...
je voulais pas que ma vidéo des 10 millions
ressemble à toutes les autres vidéos
que j’ai faites sur ma chaîne.
J’aime bien aussi faire des trucs
un peu différents,
c’est pour ça que depuis quelques années,
je fais des sketchs un peu différents,
des courts-métrages, j’ai sorti une BD...
Ca peut prendre plein de formes.
Et tout ça, depuis 10 ans, ça n’a pas changé.
Je crée toujours plein de trucs.
Il y a juste beaucoup
beaucoup plus de monde qui me suit.
Mais au fond, j’ai l’impression de faire
ce que j’ai toujours su faire : avoir des idées
et les mettre en scène comme je peux,
avec une caméra ou autre chose.
- Est-ce qu’on peut prendre une photo avec toi ?
- Bien sûr !
- On est aussi clichés l’un que l’autre !
Ca fait plaisir !
- Oui ! Personne ne me croyait !
- Bah je te crois pas non plus, donc…
(rires)
- C'est la petite victoire de la journée !
Là je vais rejoindre Thomas Gauthier,
un YouTuber de Montréal,
qui fait des vidéos depuis très très longtemps,
comme moi.
(musique d'intrigue)
Oui !!
- Ca va ?
- Merci pour l’accueil ! Dans cette magnifique ville !
- Comment t’aimes-tu Montréal ?
- J’aime beaucoup. C’est essentiellement basé
sur le froid, mais c’est une très bonne expérience.
- Prenez place, assoyez-vous.
- Eh ben c’est très agréable !
- On va jouer le jeu du choc culturel.
- Le choc culturel ?
Ah, redis ?
- Ca veut dire : "danse".
- Tout ca ? Ca veut dire "danse" ?
C'est un peu long...
- Très long !
- Est-ce validé par le représentant de la nation ?
- 10/10.
- Ca veut dire quoi ?
- Qu’il a encore de l’expérience à acquérir.
"T’as encore les croûtes à manger.
T’as encore à apprendre."
(brouhaha)
Ils se battent !
ls enlèvent les gants,
et ils se battent.
- L’affaire est ketchup ?
- "Ca passe crème" !
C'est... "l’affaire est dans le sac" !
- Est-ce qu’il y a une expression française
que tu pourrais ne pas comprendre..?
- Ca veut dire :
"y a du monde à la messe" ?
- Non, c’est une fille
qui a un grand décolleté.
- Y a du monde au balcon ?
- Y a du monde au balcon !
- Je voulais pas vous déranger,
vous êtes peut-être en train de…
J’ai une autre fan ici !
- C’est vrai ?
- Elle, je sais pas, tu connais ?
Que 2 fans…
(rires)
Que 2 fans !
J’ai deux fans là bas.
J’en ai pas trois, j’en ai deux.
- T’as pas mal de gens qui..?
- Ouais. Des jeunes surtout.
Devant une maison de retraite,
il se passe rien. Vraiment rien.
Y a de ça 48 heures, j’étais en maillot
de bain, les pieds dans l’eau !
A la recherche des poissons tropicaux !
Faut savoir que ma valise
ne ressemble à rien !
J’ai des tongs, des maillots de bain,
et ensuite des doudounes, des gants,
c’est n’importe quoi !
Il fait chaud hein ?
Il fait actuellement -7°.
Est-ce qu’il y a un coin à l’ombre ?
Tous mes membres de mon corps
vont s’arracher.
(cris de dégoût)
J’ai bu ma bière belge,
j’ai mangé mon chocolat suisse,
j’ai mangé mon rougail saucisse
à La Réunion.
C’est la première fois que je mange créole,
ça va pas être la dernière fois !
Oh merci La Réunion !
Oh la la !
J’ai eu un petit tajine au Maroc,
et puis...
la poutine de Montréal !
Alors j’ai demandé sur Twitter
quel restaurant je devais choisir.
Vous pouvez voir
que c’est un 50-50 parfait,
du coup… on va choisir Poutineville !
Parce que le nom est marrant !
La poutine de Montréal :
pommes de terre, fromage, un peu de viande
et une petite sauce brune des familles.
C’est un grand oui !
- T’es allé à Poutineville
ou t’es allé…?
Je suis allé à Poutineville !
Vous savez tout de moi, visiblement !
Je n’ai pas de secret.
C’était très bien, c’était ma première poutine,
c’était très bon, je n’ai plus faim depuis…
Je savais que j’étais attendu
dans toutes ces villes,
mais on n’arrive pas
à imaginer les gens.
D’avoir vu des visages,
d’avoir vu des sourires,
d’avoir fait des câlins,
de recevoir des cadeaux,
d’avoir fait des checks,
des selfies…
On immortalise ça ?
Ca je pouvais pas l’imaginer.
Ca c’est vraiment moi
qui vais le chercher.
Fallait que je fasse ce petit voyage
pour m’en rendre compte.
Je suis très content d'être là,
et en même temps,
je suis un peu triste parce que c’est…
- La fin ?
- C’est la fin ouais.
Je suis tellement triste qu’on arrive
à cette dernière rencontre d’abonnés.
10 millions c’est incroyable,
j’ose à peine y croire.
Et vous rendez ça très concret.
Quand je vous vois, je me dis :
voilà, c’est des vrais personnes,
des vrais gens,
c’est pas que des pseudos…
Sans vous,
je fais pas grand-chose.
Et... merci de me faire confiance !
(applaudissements)
Merci beaucoup !
On est 10 millions de propriétaires
de ce bouton !
C’est un bouton qu’on se partage tous,
sauf que c’est moi qui ai la garde ;
je suis la maman !
C’est plein de sens pour ce que je fais
depuis maintenant 10 ans sur I nternet,
et ça signifie aussi la fin de cette vidéo.
La fin de ce petit périple.
Ca a été dingue de voyager autant,
de rencontrer autant de gens,
de gens différents, de cultures différentes,
de pays différents.
C’était important pour moi
de prendre le temps, à un moment,
de partir 10 jours,
rencontrer les gens comme ça.
Des abonnés que j’ai jamais
l’occasion de rencontrer,
et je suis très content de m’être enrichi
de toutes ces rencontres.
Comment je pourrais me dire :
" Ah tiens, finalement c’est chiant…
finalement c’est pas épanouissant…
finalement c’est pas intéressant…" ?
Je peux pas…
(cris et applaudissements)
C’est un peu con de dire ça
quand on a 10 millions d’abonnés mais…
Sait-on jamais… Abonne-toi ?!
Sous titres : Aurore Taddei